[Music]
613 for women undergoing breast cancer
surgery there is an emotional
physical and mental recovery that comes
along with it
one challenge how to look your best when
you feel your worst
in today's buddy check eight denise
valdez shows us a line of adaptive
clothing for women battling breast
cancer
she would just talk about how she would
have four to six of these drains hanging
from her body
alison schickel vividly remembers the
struggle her friend wendy faced
post-surgery
and how a specific garment could help
and if you could create something
for women you know who are battling
breast cancer and undergoing the surgery
that would be amazing
so allison created the probe part bra
part robe snaps for ease pockets for
convenience
the clothing line offers thousands of
women the comfort and the confidence
they needed
but was missing from the market it
seemed like they were focused more on
the sickness of the patient and i
just had this light bulb moment of
wanting to create something that was
functional and fashionable
and focus on the wellness of the patient
bright colors designed for patients
going through mastectomy
reconstruction or augmentation it helps
disguise devices
and offer freedom this is an emotional
product this is an emotional business
that we're in and so
i like to say that we're really in the
people business we just happen to sell a
really cool product the women-owned
small business
has grown since it started 10 years ago
to even offer clothing for kids you can
see the full line of adaptive clothing
on thebrobe.com
for buddy check denise valdez 8 news now
very innovative and i'm sure the ladies
appreciate that so much
as we do here every month we encourage
women to call their buddy and remind
them
to do their monthly breast self-exam
breast cancer
is one of the most survivable if it's
caught early
nate thanks sherry